FACE THE DEATH PENALTY.
BRET?
>> Bret: LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT'S TRIP AND THE
OTHER NEWS OF THE DAY.
KELLY CONWAY JOINS US HERE ON
THE NORTH WALL
LOG.
WHY DID HE FEEL COMPELLED TO GO?
OTHERS SAID HE'S THE PRESIDENT,
HE SHOULD GO.
WHY DID THE PRESIDENT WANT TO
GO?
>> OF THE PRESIDENT NEVER
HESITATED.
HE WANTED TO BE THERE TO EXPRESS
HIS CONDOLENCES ALONG WITH THE
FIRST LADY, HIS DAUGHTER AND
SON-IN-LAW.
WITH THE PRESIDENT'S REMARKS,
VERY STRONG AGAINST
ANTI-SEMITISM.
THAT'S THE LESSON I WANT MY FOUR
CATHOLIC CHILDREN IN THE WHOLE
WORLD TO KNOW, THESE 11 INNOCENT
WERE MURDERED BECAUSE THEY WERE
JEWISH.
THAT MAN WENT IN THERE ALLEGEDLY
SAYING THAT ALL JEWS MUST DIE
AND HE WAS BENT ON MURDERING
THEM AND HE GOT HIS WAY WITH 11
OF THEM.
I WANT THEIR NAMES TO NOT BE
FORGOTTEN.
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO READ IN AND
ALSO JUST HAVE THE INSTRUCTOR
THIS OF ANTI-SEMITISM AND ITS
PRIVATE
PREVALENCE AROUND THE WORLD AND
IN PITTSBURGH OR ITS UNFORTUNATE
PEOPLE WERE OUT THERE
POLITICALLY PROTESTING WITH
DIFFERENT MESSAGES TODAY.
THIS PRESIDENT WAS NOT ABOUT
POLITICS.
HE WAS ABOUT THE MOURNING IN
PITTSBURGH.
>> Bret: DO YOU EXPECT THE
PRESIDENT TO SPEAK MORE ABOUT
THIS, WHITE NATIONALISM,
ANTI-SEMITISM?
>> HE'S BEEN DOING THIS ALL
ALONG.
PEOPLE SHOULD READ HIS TWEETS,
LISTEN TO HIM ON SATURDAY WHEN
HE GAVE THOSE REMARKS, HEARTFELT
REMARKS.
THOSE OF US WHO DISCUSSED THIS
PARTICULAR TRAGEDY, AND ACTIVE
ACT OF,
VILE HATRED.
HE TRIED TO EXPRESS TO THE
COUNTRY.
PEOPLE WILL LOOK UP TODAY WITH
HER THE LAST HOUR TRULY MOVED BY
WHAT THEY SEE IN THE SENSELESS
LOSS AND ACTIVE EVIL THERE.
THIS PRESIDENT SHOWED UP IN
LAS VEGAS AND PARTS OF FLORIDA.
HE'S BEEN THERE FOR NATURAL
DISASTERS, FOR HIM THIS IS MORE
OF A NATURAL PLACE FOR HIM TO BE
THAT PEOPLE GIVE THEM CREDIT FO
FOR.
>> Bret: THE OTHER ISSUE TODAY
IS HE TOLD AXIOS THAT HE
POSSIBLY WANTS TO SIGN AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO CHANGE
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP.
>> OBVIOUSLY CANNOT DO THAT.
YOU CANNOT END BIRTHRIGHT
CITIZENSHIP WITH AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
WE DIDN'T LIKE IT WHEN OBAMA
TRIED TO CHANGE IMMIGRATION LAWS
WITH CONSECUTIVE DOWN THE
EXECUTIVE
ACTION.
WE BELIEVE IN THE CONSTITUTION.
>> AS CONSPIRATORS WE BELIEVE IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
ANY RESPONSE?
>> AS WE DO.
-- YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN OVER A
YEAR, BRET, SINCE THE PRESIDENT
INTRODUCED HIS 70-POINT
IMMIGRATION PLAN, THEN HE GOT IT
DOWN TO FOUR POINTS.
BUILD THE WALL, THE VISA
LOTTERY, AND MAX CHAIN
MIGRATION.
FOUR VERY SIMPLE CONCEPTS, ALL
WHICH PAUL VERY WELL, BY THE
WAY, WITH LARGE SWATHS OF
AMERICANS.
NOT JUST THE BASE.
CONGRESS NEVER ACTED.
ON BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP, 30
COUNTRIES TO HAVE IT, BUT ONLY
TWO IN THE "DEVELOPER WORLD" AS
THE IMF DEFINES IT, CANADA AND
THE U.S., MOST PARTS OF ASIA,
MANY PARTS OF ASIA DON'T HAVE IT
MANY PARTS OF ASIA DON'T HAVE I.
MANY OTHER CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLARS HAVE SAID THAT THE 14TH
AMENDMENT HAS BEEN
MISINTERPRETED OR MISUSED IN
THIS WAY.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THERE HAVE
BEEN USE REPORTS WHERE WOMEN PAY
A LOT OF MONEY, MAYBE MONEY THEY
DON'T REALLY DON'T HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE CHILDREN ARE
BORN HERE.
THE IDEA THAT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AND IT'S NOT GOING ON IN THE
THOUSANDS, THE IDEA THAT IT'S
NOT UNIQUE TO THE U.S., CANADA,
THE DEVELOPER WORLD?
IT'S FALSE.
>> Bret: WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
THE PEOPLE WHO LOOK AT THIS FROM
A ONE WEEK AWAY FROM THE
ELECTION DAY, THIS IS ABOUT
STIRRING THE POT, GETTING PEOPLE
FIRED UP.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS OUT THERE,
HE'S IN PITTSBURGH TO EXPRESS
HIS CONDOLENCES, FOR THIS
VIOLENT, ANTI-SEMITIC ACT, BUT
ON THE OTHER DAYS CAN BE HE'S
OUT THERE CAMPAIGNING FOR
CANDIDATES WHO HE SAYS WILL HELP
SUPPORT HIS AGENDA.
HE TALKS ABOUT FREE-MARKET
HEALTH CARE.
HE TALKS ABOUT TAX CUTS.
TALKS ABOUT THE REGULATION.
TALK THAT HE TRIED TO MEET WITH
KIM JONG IL AND TO GET
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE KOREAN
PENINSULA WHICH HELPS EVERYONE.
WE HAVE DETAINEES AND HOSTAGES
THAT ARE COMING BACK HOME.
HE TALKS ABOUT IMMIGRATION -- HE
TALKS ABOUT IMMIGRATION IN MANY
WAYS.
BORDER SECURITY, NATIONAL
SECURITY, TALKS ABOUT COMING TO
THIS COUNTRY LEGALLY THROUGH
LEGAL PORT OF ENTRY.
THERE ARE 26 OF THEM.
LAST YEAR WE HAD 38,000 -- WE
PROCESSED 38,000 CLAIMS OF
CRITICAL FEAR?
THAT'S A RECORD.
DHS SAID OVER HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE TRIED TO CROSS OVER
ILLEGALLY, OF TICKETED CHILDREN
BEING SMUGGLED, UPTAKE IN THE
NUMBER OF ASSAULTS HAPPENING.
THAT'S NOT EVERYBODY, BUT WHY
ARE WE TURNING A BLIND EYE?
THEY ALL SIGNED ONTO THE
FEINSTEIN PLANNED AND BASICALLY
LOOKED THE OTHER WAY.
BORDER SECURITY, NATIONAL
SECURITY, THIS PRESIDENT HAS
TALKED ABOUT IT FOR MANY YEARS.
AND HELP THEM GET ELECTED.
>> Bret: ONE OF THE TWEETS
DURING THE PYTHON MAILINGS THAT
THE PRESIDENT SET
SENT OUT --
SHE'S TURNING THE PAGE.
IS THAT WHAT HE'S SEEING NOW?
>> THE PRESIDENT SENDS MANY
TWEETS IN MANY DIFFERENT TOPICS.
WE HAVE TO TAKE TOTALITY OF HIS
TWEETS AND TOTALITY OF HIS
PRESIDENCY.
ABOUT THE TIME HE WAS SENDING
THAT TWEET WITHIN A DAY OR SO,
HE HAD AN UNBELIEVABLE EVENT
HERE WITH BLACK AMERICANS.
HE CAME ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TO SAY THAT WE ARE NOT ALL
DEMOCRATS.
WE SUPPORT THE DEMOCRATS
-- AND THAT GOT VERY LITTLE
COVERAGE.
COVERAGE WAS THAT HE WAS BEING
DERIDED BY OTHERS AND HE
SPEAKING UP FOR THEMSELVES.
THIS PRESIDENT DOES NOT SEE THE
MOMENTUM SLOWED DOWN IN SO FAR
AS HE'S OUT THERE RUNNING FOR
THE TAPE LIKE IT DID IN 2016.
DOES A RECORD NUMBER OF
PRESIDENTIAL VISITS BETWEEN
LABOR DAY AND ELECTION DAY FOR